with the pickup of a Porsche and the
strongest batteries on the road for two
years the Tesla Model S has been the
king of green luxury cars already twenty
five thousand are on the streets of the
US so why are they tweaking with
perfection this is a Tesla s like you've
never seen it before for the first time
ever the steering wheel is on the right
side of the car inside all the bells and
whistles expect it's on the 17 inch
display a full ipad size vision of
Google Maps going up tracking my energy
consumptions brains and up here voice
control play mmm dessert it's a minor
tweet for Tesla founder Elon Musk who's
betting Britain will be his top market
in Europe the UK's is likely to be one
of our most significant markets
somewhere between three and three four
or five I would guess I so far our
advance orders are very strong in the UK
in fact if you order a car now you'd
only receive it in about four months
we're also putting a lot of effort as I
mentioned into supercharger
infrastructure we want to have southern
England covered by at the end of this
year and all of the British Isles of I
dated next year so the infrastructure
build-out is quite significant will be
spending several tens of millions of
dollars in over the next year on that
that starts at fifty thousand pounds
must flew to London to turn over the
keys to the first five new owner
among them the best-selling author of
Fifty Shades of Grey it's super famous
and it's super green I mean it's just
ticks all the boxes in it it's beautiful
the beautiful form that really thought
about it
everything must coax right-side steering
wheels will springboard Tesla into other
countries where people drive on the left
side of the road including India and his
native South Africa charging the cars
though there will still be a challenge
without the infrastructure in place
meanwhile in Britain these new
supercharger stations may prove to be
the key for Tesla to make major new
inroads Olivia Sterns Bloomberg